so we're very very pleased to have him
with us today thanks a lot
I in the spirit of the of the classroom
that I like to teach I I don't have a
lot of visuals those are memory aids I
hope that the approach that I've chosen
will be sufficiently interesting to
substitute for the bells and whistles
that their problem we're used to can you
hear me
please feel free to interrupt me at any
point what I've chosen to do was is to
anticipate a dialogue I thought it would
be interesting to itemize what I has the
nine most frequently heard or at least
most frequently heard by me errors or
let's say half-truths or somewhere
between zero percent truths and 58
percent truths that are generally in
play when people talk whether in text
books or in American politics or in
there's general cultural reference about
the movement against the Vietnam War so
I'm in a sense presuming to anticipate
or preempt your some of your questions
but I'm sure I'm missing the ones that
are most challenging and most subtle so
these are the ones I think that I've
heard most over the years and let me
actually by way just by way of a
prologue it wouldn't be surprising that
people would be badly misinformed about
the
movement against the war partly because
Americans are badly misinformed about
most matters Isis so the other day
recent poll apropos the energy bill that
just passed the House last week asked
people not sure exactly how the question
was formulated and that matters but
anyway the scuttlebutt is and it's
completely plausible to me when people
were asked what is cap-and-trade
one-quarter of people knew it was knew
that it referred to a system for
allocating permits to emit greenhouse
guests so no surprise what Americans are
asked about geography or about history
including our own history we're not very
good at it and I I'm not even sure that
what Americans know about the Vietnam
War actually surpasses what they know
about the movement against them we leave
these two things and I gather that this
is part of what I'm doing here these two
things should really be twice as at one
of the peace I mean they they are the
same story accurate if they are two
facets of the same story unfortunately
this is much been missed and this is
partly because there's something about
the movement against the Vietnam War
that's still deeply unsettling in the in
the minds of what I loosely call the
establishment a number of years ago you
know there's this wonderful series
published called the library of America
they have been publishing great American
writers for twenty thirty years these
there were there were only uniformed
beautiful looking black editions with
with uniform white I think labels and
beautiful one of those old-fashioned
sort of ribbons keep your place small
print very carefully edited a number of
years ago I think was maybe 20 in the
Library of America series which largely
consists of writers like Thoreau and
Emerson and so on there appeared a
volume called
reporting the reporting of Vietnam War
and it was a compilation two volumes on
journalism about the Vietnam War and it
there's a lot of wonderful journalism
that was written about them so it
certainly deserves to be there but it is
at the 30 least peculiar that there is
nothing in there about the repose of
reporting that's representative of the
reporting of the anti-war movement which
was in the AnnaLynne in the in the I
would say as a sort of amateur historian
of journalism in the history of American
journalism is at least as important just
strictly as journalism the leaning side
here one's views about the war there's
nothing it has to do with what is the
contour what are the contours of
American history in the contras American
history the anti were moving looms very
large if you need any proof of it
consider that I think it's true although
it may not quite be true that the last
presidential election panel we had will
be the last but I've said this before
that in which ones in which the question
of where presidential candidates were
and what they were doing was smoking
heat during the Vietnam War was an issue
maybe it'll come up again it's
conceivable it will come up again
because we may have seen the last of
that but here it is now 40 years long
and the anti-war movement and the
controversies about the war are still
alive this is not a finished history any
more than the Vietnam assist so
let me go to so it's not surprising that
there are obfuscation x' evasions
embarrassments repressions for you would
say that have stood in the way of people
seeing the vietnam war movement as but
not simply a momentary effusion I will
argue this actually essential rivulet in
American history but I will I will come
to that later on so let me let me
proceed to cap truths interestingly
enough in recent years there's been in
popular culture a fair amount of
sentimentality about the movement
against the Vietnam War
maybe one of the greatest expressions of
that is in the is in the movie made from
the play from the musical hair which
which i think is actually quite
wonderful but whatever you think of it
as it there's a piece of film there is
in that I never saw the play I don't
know if this is true in the play but it
certainly is a feeling that generates in
the last and a closing scene in Central
Park if you saw the film that there was
some sort of spectacular overcoming of
boundaries some sort of a collective
burst of mutual recognition community
joy and courage perhaps a truthfulness
all coming together in some sort of
momentous eruption and it's become
fairly routine now actually it's been
fairly routine for last
again I think back into the 70s that
films that touch on the Vietnam War
films that touch on the movement I
should say include a scene in which the
in which anti-war demonstrators are
either demonized that is
black workers or something of that sort
or they are sentimentalize as sort of
the sweetest people you ever thought to
me and but I mean interested for the
moment of it but first half truth or
minor fractional truth that I want to
address is the sentimental version in
which in which says that maybe except
for those people were actually fighting
the Vietnam War that the anti-war
movement was great popular cause and
certainly the anti-war boot itself as
told is often veterans of movement have
told this story themselves ourselves so
flattering it's also by the way it's not
simply a story is told in the United
States it's a story that's told around
the world I believe I've never been
there myself but I believe that it's a
story that sometimes called in Vietnam
itself because the official Vietnamese
idea about how they won the war was that
they had is that the war was unpopular
with the American people and when the
American people came to realize just how
bad it was they threw up their
collective arms and and and and walked
away from well that's a hand it's a
partial truth because eventually that
did turn out to be the case eventually
the anti-war movement was extremely
popular but I think what's important to
realize in getting the historical
parameters right is that when the
Vietnam War began that turns out to be a
complicated question but for a number of
years the Vietnam War was vastly popular
at the time of the great but I don't I
don't need to review the through the
elements of the history of the world but
you know that the great escalation took
place in the spring of 1965 and at that
time when committed Johnson sent troops
sent Marines fighting troops were not
any longer
presentable as advisors and began to be
steady bombing of North Vietnam for me
there at that period when we when
polling agencies started regularly to
assess public opinion toward American
policy American policy met with to pull
a figure out of my memory eighty-one
percent approval with something like
fifteen percent disapproving and the
rest of undecided and if we have a piece
of trouble
so if we were to look at the entire as
you know we could start looking at this
during Kennedy years but let's sort of
arbitrarily decide we're going to start
looking at it 1965 where we have this
all this 50% approval 1,800 so we're
starting here in early 1965 at about 80
now
it was not until 1968 that public
disapproval sorry
public disapproval reached the 50/50
percent one continue to decline so
during the period but my point of the
anti-war movement rubber most of it
which is a period from 1965 through 1969
or less let's go into 1970 during mooses
period for much of it and certainly
during them run to it the ento were the
more movement was a popular cause there
were larger pro-war demonstrations than
were anti-war demonstrations at least
until 1967 there were parades down Fifth
Avenue organized by groups like the
Veterans of Foreign Wars supporting the
war and calling for not only the
escalation of the war frequently but
also for the punishment of anti-war
demonstrators there were there were
demonstrations on campuses where
anti-war demonstrators were beaten up by
pro war by pro war supporters and I'm
not talking about backwater sort of
campus I'm talking about like Indiana
University and the University of
Michigan
so so much for the first erroneous
assumption that the anti or moving was
all the rage were all the time
second it's generally believed and again
I think this is a an image that's deeply
embedded in popular culture that the
that the center or the predominant
population involved in the anti-war
movement were students this is connected
then to I might as well include this
here a sort of attendant myth that the
anti-war movement was fundamentally an
anti draft movement that is it was a it
was a protect urself movement now
there's a there is some truth to the
second but let me let me first establish
that the student part of it while it
certainly wasn't a core dynamic that was
led by anti-war students is by no means
the whole story first of all it might
surprise you to know as part of this
along with this mythology comes the
general the conventional belief that it
was educated Americans who opposed the
war and uneducated or less educated
Americans who supporter that one is
pretty straightforwardly false the more
education you had the more likely you
were to support the Vietnam War the less
money you had
and money and education tend to go
together the more likely you'll pose if
that doesn't mean you were more likely
to resist it and that this Amin will
more likely to participate in the
anti-war movement which is
demographically vents the fact you're
talking to interested in how there were
two other important popular I mean the
planter were moving by 1968 was a in
immensity it was a mass movement it was
a movement that millions of people
participated and participating here
meaning anything from I'm going to quit
my job and devote myself to opposing
this war to I'm going to abandon my from
my metals over the fence but there were
two populations that are especially
important in understanding the
demography the sociology at the end of
one is that the population with whom the
war was least popular was
african-americans and so even at a time
when large numbers of students were
still burning or siding with the war we
ready began to see around nineteen even
in 1965 in 1966 expressions of anti-war
sentiment on public expressions
demonstrations at draft boards public
statements if drafted I will not serve a
black statement to that effect was
published in Mississippi in 1965 one
reason we don't know this story so well
is the same reason we don't we know more
about the doings of educated ternasky
largely white people in America
uneducated which is disproportionately
non annoying people and therefore no
surprise the demonstration at a
university campus is a much bigger story
than a statement by a bunch of black
people in Mississippi that they
disapprove of Vietnam so that needs to
be born online the second population
that is is almost always neglected and I
think I've actually neglected it to some
anybody for certain reasons in my own
book when the anti-war movement has
talked about has to do with you Armed
Forces the this is something I don't
really want to take a lot of time on but
on happy to answer questions about it
beginning in 1966 and certainly
accelerating considerably in 1968 1969
there was a vast movement of soldiers of
on on duty personnel military personnel
in all the Armed Services that took
Nathan that took the form of publication
of anti-war newspapers at which there
were literally hundreds they took the
form of soldiers in Vietnam to go to
going AWOL in Missouri and even
attacking and sometimes killing their
officers the practice that was frequent
enough to actually have a slang term
attack schools called fragging to such a
point
that by 1970 which is to say still
several meters from the end of the war
the military itself was deeply alarmed
about the condition of the Armed Forces
and the demoralization that had spread
significantly because of the Vietnam War
because the war was still being fought
with draftees plunder and if this is
very important I would say maybe the
most important motive for converting the
Armed Forces from a draft system from
conscription system into a volunteer
system which we have to this day an
article was published on refer to it in
my book by a chronal an Army colonel in
the armed force of journal in 1970 that
included some extraordinary statistic
business objective this is an army
Colonels report on the incidence of drug
abuse drug addiction a walls desertions
fragging to someone in the armed
services the quotes from that I mean
it's almost sounds like something lured
out of an underground newspaper the
language that's used by this Colonel
language of the order of the American
armed forces armed unravelling
dissolving in this was
my main disadvantage in military is so
one reason to one reason to cast a
skeptical eye on the view that's that
the movement against the world was a
student is to reflect on how we form
such images ten forms such images out of
media coverage and media coverage is
more interested in general and has
greater access to the doings of
university students than soldiers who
are living on isolated bases or even in
other countries whose doings whether a
criminal or or not are simply less
accessible to but there's another aspect
of this story about the students that is
terribly important and it bears on the
sort of footnote
pending to the second point namely the
claim that the movement against the war
was largely moving against the graph
that is to say the movement against the
war was a movement on the court of
college age of draft age men who simply
didn't want to go to Vietnam now there
is that this is not a walled city but
it's a distortion and the proof of it is
this from nineteen well from the
beginning up through 1966 if you were in
college if you were a student enrolled
in a college or a professional school
you were actually exempt from the draft
in fact one way of calling attention to
yourself and making yourself more
susceptible to the draft was by
resisting the draft or publicly opposing
the war I have a friend from those years
who's now a Canadian citizen and rights
lawyer but once upon a time hailed from
Cincinnati Ohio and became a went on his
way to becoming a Canadian in 1966 when
he was one of the first Americans who
instead of just sort of disappearing
from the traffic or by what he did he
did what some of the more militant
people were doing in those years not
huge numbers he wrote he sent his draft
card back to he said his red car back to
his draft board that in Kansas where he
was organizing
student protests was was a short ticket
to a court date in federal court and
when he stood up and refusing to
acknowledge the authority to be judged
stood there with his back turned he was
sentenced to I forget how long
that was when he started his trip to
Canada he if he had simply been an
enrolled student does anything before he
would have been in no danger being
graphic why were college students he
would understand obviously I'm talking
only about men why why were college
students exempt because the draft was
set up to play favorites it was not even
worse around I can tell you how we know
that we know there are actually
documents that were on earth they show
that this was a strategy of the
Selective Service System the draft
system in order to encourage people to
get a higher education and reward them
for doing so that was one of the rewards
as every year after you're 18 you
register for the draft and you're 18 and
you filled out a form every year I
believe was every year you were quiz you
know are you still a college student as
long as to a college student you got an
automatic defer
and if you just stayed in school long
enough eventually by the time you were
26 or so they were no longer interested
well technically we're still eligible to
35 so so during this period when the
anti-woman was actually accelerated the
to be an active anti-war activist was
actually from the point of view of
self-preservation and stupidest thing
you could have done a smart thing would
have been to shut up
go to school this change beginning in
1966 when the Selective Service System
started to run out of material and began
a series of moves of details I won't go
into to encourage college students to to
figure out how to divide eligible
college students but unintelligible
sometimes my grades sometimes by by
taking a college-wide test and so on so
well it was certainly true by 1967 and
certainly even more in 1968 that that
one strong motive to oppose the war was
that you didn't want yourself to go to
Vietnam that certainly is true but it
wasn't true at the beginning and so
while so the argument that the anti
worms was essentially an anti crafts
movement has a certain applicability in
the later but not at the beginning okay
a third half truth this was a movement
of young people and in the collective
imagination is overlaps with the last
point
overlapping with the notion that they
were substantial students we have a a
collective imagery which is again not
false which associate the movement
against the war with what came to be
called the counterculture so it seems
that somehow it's maybe all of the peace
Woodstock is symbolic hearing a lot
about that this summer us were up on 48
hours and so it sort of seems like there
were these people who were wild have
long hair whatever sex they were did a
lot of drugs that was certainly that's
not a falsity but it's a distortion
because from the beginning there were
substantial numbers of people it's
impossible to quantify those involved
even seriously and devotedly involve in
viento we're moving who or not young for
example just a point of local reference
one of these one of the important
organizations from quite early on
through the entire Vietnam War in
organizing activities making public
statements about the war it's open it's
a group called clergy and laity
concerned against the Vietnam see ALC
one of the central people in that
organization was the was the minister at
Riverside Church down the street with
his own coffin
and that group had more staying power I
would say you were a consistency and
eventually became quite large I was
largely an organization religious a
flirt of Protestant clergy
well no proximate Catholic book there
were separate organizations and then
we're also rabbis involved so there was
that asked the time wore on in between
1965 and 1968 if you looked at photos of
people and demonstrators it would become
clear to you that the later it is the
more the population was visible in
demonstrations resembles the American
population in a whole it's not just it's
not Woodstock it's sort of a mix of
Woodstock and the 4th of July
it's suburban you know the proverbial
soccer moms with work I guess there were
two soccer moms yeah they were probably
basketball
it looked by 1969 which I'll come back
to in a minute it was it was an American
Apple Ponton demographically
along with the previous half-truths
partial truths is the notion that the
end oh well there are two versions of it
here but but one version which I'll is
that this was a this was entirely or
primarily a radical movement that is to
say was a movement primarily of people
who wanted to make fundamental changes
fundamental reforms in the organization
of American society across the board now
it certainly is true that the anti-war
movement was kicked off by radicals by
these specifically groups like when I
was involved with students for a
Democratic Society and the earliest
example the earliest demonstration kind
of organized the national demonstration
against the Vietnam War in 1965 was
organized by by that group but it was it
was attended by people who are not
radical students kind of amusing when we
think of what associations radical as
these days of people if you look at
photos of that demonstration and I have
another book you see that scored
remember those students in radical
students were picketing the White House
are wearing jackets and ties you know
the skirts and blouses it's it's it's
not
and he was a significant number you'll
see there were significant number of
african-americans at that demonstration
and there was a significant number of
adults the radicals happy initiative in
the early period of the anteroom and
radicals here were not all of a piece
some believed in organizing big
demonstrations some believed in
organizing civil disobedience actions
some wanted more symbolic sort of
protests I mean if you're interested we
can go into the various colorations
but again as time went on two things
happen first of all the radical wing of
the movement which had many fish to fry
had many political objectives tended to
depart from the leadership of the
anti-war it was doing other things
especially trying to address racial
issues and increasingly the leadership
of the anti-war movement turned in the
direction of a number of other forces
among whom were were groups very far
from and by 1968 nine
it wasn't even entirely clear they could
speak of a single anti-world in fact in
part a more moderate I'm not sure that's
the right word but it's the media words
the more moderate sectors of the
movement began to manifest itself partly
in opposition to or in a desire to
differentiate itself from the more
radical city so it's just an example in
1969 and this deserves a very serious
commemoration this fall
a group of increasingly there were there
were students as well as non students
who were kind of you know really
mainstream sort of people like student
government presidents and college
newspaper prisoners increasingly active
against the Vietnam and people who came
out of that Madhu core uneasy because
increasingly it looked as though the
more militant anti-war people had the
initiative they decided quite
deliberately and self-consciously
to organize activity that wasn't
confrontational that was a chemical and
welcoming to people who were not
especially radical at all
and their their big maiden activity was
in October 1969 a group of of organizers
declared what they called a moratorium
and the idea was that on a 15th day of
October people would not do what they
ordinarily do they would do something
else whatever whatever they felt like it
might be if you lived in a small town
you'd go out to the you know the civil
war monument and hold the Silent Hill
individual you might be organizing a
petition campaign directed at members of
Congress or local politicians mid-swing
and they were also big demonstration and
the idea was tober 15th would be the one
day when all this would take place and
if the war didn't end then in November
it would be two days and and then so on
from the middle of every month a day
would be added well it lasted two months
but it was amiss it was immense and the
moratorium of October 15th brought out
quite literally millions of people there
was no central place it was highly
dispersed by November there was so much
momentum behind this movement that we
did go to two days and the radicals
actually split off so there were
actually two sets of activities in
nineteen November 1969 there was a very
orderly giant orderly demonstration in
Washington and it was a very unruly calm
additional sending violent demonstration
so bear in mind that the movement was
not just a you know it was not all
radical in it in terms of numbers of
people involved again this is guesswork
I think it's pretty safe to say that a
vastly larger number of Americans in
1969 identified with a more moderate
part of the movement the movement like
the portrait yeah there was a chapter of
students for democratic society here
probably as early as 1964 and it was
even a kind of liberal protest group
before that but they my I was a here
then but my understanding is that they
were it would finally intellectualized
group and as SDS was becoming less
intellectualize they would sort of act
odds they were doing research about
university doings and so on they were
trying to figure out a way to relate to
black people in Harlem but they weren't
actually that visible although their
numbers were growing and it wasn't until
1968 when they decided they were going
to be a kind of militant
you know and it seems the term of the
time action faction that they became
renowned outside Columbia was not in the
first wave of the student organizations
but I would say it was in in the second
research here well yeah that certainly
wasn't organization in place and they
were actually two organizations in place
they were STS which everybody knew about
that there was also the african-american
students who actually without whom there
would have been no demonstrations at all
that's another story but yes okay number
I think I'm up to number six one partial
truth again this is more this is
something one this is inundated probably
is a live in about a quarter of a minute
okay and it is that the movement against
the work was a pro surrender
pro-communist and it became in politic
to say that in recent news because this
is still IV charter petition the word in
Vietnam today is quite unpopular with
Americans so it's not even George Bush
who clearly believes this you McCain is
more interesting complicated case but
certainly George Bush who certainly
believe this never said so in so many
words on the campaign trail that would
be done
but it is true that there were people
increasingly there were only very few in
1964-65 by 1969 or so 68 it was not
uncommon to see people at anti-war
demonstrations carrying Vietcong were
North Vietnamese flags and making
extravagant statements
virtues
Koshien
leaders of nationalist communist
they they were real and they became
increasingly well positioned in
organizations like SDS demons for
Democratic Society by 1968 or so as
increasingly they began to think of
themselves as revolutionaries but even
at their peak they were never mature
everything more close to a majority even
of the members of a radical organization
like this because there was much more a
tragic sense that the war was
unsustainable it was immoral that it was
also doomed and therefore that it was
sad but true fact that the best thing
that could happen for both on earth and
Vietnam would be for the United States's
withdrawal but that was different from
exuberance about the
virtues of the other side and
again by far the majority of the anti
world didn't think the war was admirable
didn't think it was moral didn't think
it was perfectly sensible didn't think
it was premise on on logic or evidence
but that's not the same thing as saying
that they were a pro communist okay
there are one other I mentioned the idea
that the movement I'm sorry
was it was there the growth of program
that's anywhere tied to the fact that
the administration was kind of labeling
anybody who was anti-war as I mean no
because they flocked I mean as a tactic
just be certainly of the Johnson
administration tried very hard to make
the case publicly that this was not a
native grown movement that this was a
specifically communist financed and
instigated and there's a funny story
that illustrates how weird one of the
first actually I was about to talk about
the press so this will come up here on
all group I'll speak to this in the
context of speaking to another idea
which is that the movement was
instigated by the media a very common
idea on the part of people in the Nixon
administration and still very much this
is the inception of the idea that the
liberal media have warped America
actually I think good clothes studies of
including will show you that for the
most part up through 1967 media coverage
was generally quite respectful until the
mainstream media covered the television
networks the major newspapers wire
services and so it's quite respectful of
the American war effort and certainly
not opposed to it it was sometimes
skeptical about how whether what the
government was saying was true but it
was not it was not in some sense biased
against the American effort or military
but one of the early pieces one of the
early pieces that that really did shake
some people in America who weren't yet
opposed to was a piece on 60 minutes no
sorry on the CBS Evening News in 1965
that was done by somebody later I think
maybe he's still at 60 minutes Morley
Safer where they say we'll send a young
reporter in and he was where they
believe was a Marine unit in village
name cam name and he appeared narrated
affected support peace with the one that
doctored a lot of people upset including
the White House was one in which Marines
set fire to pots with cigarette lighter
with Civic Center lighters
so the cuts go up and there's
considerable it's been reported and I'm
and nobody's ever disputed that the
White House was severely unhappy about
this and in fact that Johnson himself
told the illegally told the head of the
CIA to invest well maybe wasn't it
they said he wanted an investigation to
see whether Morley Safer was a communist
and at least tonight I take back what I
said earlier the reason was it illegal
CIA isn't supposed to be mucking around
in America but we're the safer was a
Canadian I'm not surely as though
Canadian citizens but he was Native
community it's still here in his bowels
and so they sent an investigation they
sent investigators to Canada they really
summed with the Canadian Mounted Police
and so they went around knocking on you
know they went to visit Sabres mother or
they went to visit his childhood
neighbor to find out what all this was
eventually the head of the CIA came back
to the White House Richard Helms was his
name and he reported that they've been
looking into this very closely
but sorry mr. president we have to tell
you he's not a communist he's just a
Canadian and to which Johnson is
supposed to sit I knew he wasn't in
America so it'll be there was something
of a it was not helpful to the Johnson
administration to try to pin all this on
Congress
it wasn't because there weren't people
in the population who were quite agree
with it and this was still we were still
in the Cold War but the the story of
what was going on war was itself much
bigger than these charges and the
horrors of the war images of which
Americans did be cold did not help the
cause
now this bill doesn't settle the
question of whether what part the media
played in developing this and people
would still still argue about it it's a
very interesting question very difficult
to make the case but I I offer as a
reason for skepticism another diagram
I would if I had
here okay this this is a I draw this
from a political scientist at Ohio State
named John Muir who I first heard talk
about this in 1983 and I found it quite
convincing let's so we have this threat
this is this is this is the story of
American public opinion but here's
here's another graph of public opinion
I mean these to be the same curve this
is visit this graphs public opinions for
another American war and it is in fact a
Korean War
which of course is much
that has started out with when North
Korea invaded South Korea 80 plus
percent supported the intervention
became less and less popular because it
was perceived as being stalled just as
the Vietnam War was procedures installed
so this is curious isn't it here's
Vietnam during which there was
television live of nothing but I mean a
rapid response television and there was
also an anti working here's a Korea very
little television coverage there very
little television news by the way it was
not until 1963 that CBS and NBC went to
30-minute news broadcast in 15 minutes
not until 1967 that ABC join them so
here he had Berg little TV coverage and
well of course it was war coverage it
was this is during the height of the
most fervent anti-communist feeling and
in American media there were very few
journalists
Department or raise serious questions
about the American version of and
moreover there was almost no anti-war
movement so business interested how can
we account for the fact that we have the
same trajectory of public opinion in
these two very different cases well a
couple of numbers I think essentially an
answer the question a couple of numbers
with the number here is 58,000 and a
number here is thirty and you know what
those numbers refer to those are
American dead I think it's not generally
understood that the Korean War which
lasted only four years actually killed
more American soldiers per year than the
numbers are commensurable same order of
magnitude I think what this demonstrates
is that the primary impetus to the
declining popularity of these wars was
number one the mounting of American
casualties number two in a war that was
perceived as not being well conducted
that is to say failing it was perceived
as failing white eisenhower was elected
in 1952 on a platform not just because
he was a general but because he did not
promise to accelerate the Korean War
this big campaign slogan I will go to
Korea I will go to Korea meaning I will
negotiate us out of this many people
believe that their to Nixon campaigned
on the equivalent remember Nixon had
been Eisenhower's vice president many
people believed that Nixon when he
hinted that he
I await and the war was trying to evoke
a similar sort of expectation that we
were stuck in this war which Nixon asked
for well heck not that's true and that
he would face us out of this doomed
situation in just the way Eisenhower
faces in that it's more sad about all
this but it's certainly a lot to be said
about the media but just if we're
talking about arguments spent how the
war ended then I don't think you can say
that either the media or the anti-war
movement was by itself a sufficient
condition now that brings me to my final
point the counterpart myth
to what I just said is the idea that
well I think many people do believe
including some people who were involved
in the into a little bit himself that
the movement had no effect on that that
administration's from if not Kennedy
which people was which is debatable but
certainly unimportant of both Johnson
and Nixon were so resolved to commit
resources bodies treasure that the war
was sort of rolled over the anti-war
opposition by the tank well not exactly
so how can that be I'm just argued that
if we look at the state of public
opinion that that the public opinion
was toward the war was declining
regardless of whether but here's how I
can say that it's mythological to say
that the movement had no effect on there
are specific jumpers in which the
president's both Johnson and Nixon were
acutely aware of the anti-war and
actually hesitated to escalate because
of their fear of public reaction I give
you just for simplicity sake I'll give
you two examples the first was in the
fall of 1969 I told I mentioned the the
moratorium Minister we know now we did
not know that I should say that when
when when these giant demonstrations
took place in for the White House fall
of 69
the White House let it be known that the
president was so oblivious so
indifferent to this display of opinion
that he wasn't even gonna be paying
attention he's gonna be watching a
football game
and that wasn't true that was that was a
cover story the truth was that Nixon
hoped then to bring a rapid end to the
war with a radical escalation an
operation was in hadn't worked out with
the joint chief you know it even had a
name it was called from some reason I
don't understand
operation dumb book operation duck hook
was to include a whole series of
escalations that would take place either
simultaneously or near simultaneously it
aimed to demonstrate to the North
Vietnamese day they would be obliterated
unless they compete really among the
measures of escalation that were
envisioned were the landing of Marines
north of the 17th parallel in North
Vietnam the invasion of both Laos and
Cambodia in order to get to North
Vietnamese and Viet Cong bases the
mining of Haiphong Harbor made a major
harboring this so which all the shipping
times there were other measures that all
lesser measures but the was also
envisioned the conceivable use of
tactical nuclear battlefield weapons so
it was awesome that was operational Co
the operation operation duck hook was
called off because of the protests of
the Fallen axis and nobody knew this at
the time nobody knew that it existed
Seymour Hersh one of our great
investigative reporters first published
this in his book about Emma Kissinger
that came out of it
early eighties and it's subsequently
been we affirm the fear of the country
just being torn apart by protests
convinced Nixon this was it
it wasn't it Nixon didn't end up doing
some of those things
didn't they cambodian 1970 he did invade
laos in 1971 he did mine harvard and my
father did not use and but because these
measures were spread out over numbers
they didn't have the overwhelming weight
that they would have had so this is a
very concrete example as good as history
generally affords of a movement actually
having a specific in the second example
of you again is connected to this has to
do with the invasion of Cambodia which
took place in I believe April 30th 1970
what that precipitated Nixon made the
announcement of what he called an
incursion of American troops who had
been bombing secretly bombing in very
long time it's noticeably ground troops
are gonna be sent to invade Cambodia
it was an amazing outpouring during that
week the week of April 30th
a majority of believe it or not a
majority of American students for the
first and only time
demonstrated against the escalation in
fact it was one of those demonstrations
against the escalation that was fired
upon by the National Guard at Kent State
University resulting in the deaths part
of that week effective and the and one
concrete result was that it is that
Nixon felt that it was politic for him
and then to announce that this that the
troops were going to be withdrawn by the
enemy so again there was this very
specific concrete reaction to an
anti-war active so there are others but
I don't know there are other such
moments in which it becomes evident that
the anti-war movement actually was a for
was a political force that like all
other political forces was taken into
account by the people who were making
many more examples of this in a book
written by former student of mine Tom
Welles called in
he went around in a very rigorous way
because why it was officially his
dissertation and interviewed not only a
lot of anti-war activists but a lot of
people in fact almost everybody who was
anybody in the in the governments of
both of Kennedy Nixon
Kennedy Johnson Nixon trying to work out
how they understood me into how they
dealt with it
this was his so let me just make one
final point I believe that the anti-war
movement was one of the most effective
and widespread social movement upheavals
in American history and in fact I was
once at a conference same place where I
met John Muir taught me things soon
numbers 1983 where I made this a point
in public I claimed that the anti-war
movement was the most effective anti-war
movement in history during a break in
the conference men came up to me one of
the few people at the conference who
actually worked in the Kennedy
administration he had been actually the
one of the key Vietnam advisors Manning
Roger Mills a professional State
Department Pro who in itself I
subsequently in one of the galleries
came up to me and he said you know what
you said about the most effective
anti-war movement that's not true I said
what what do you mean what was more
effective the Bolshevik Revolution
technically he's related in a way he was
right he accept that the Bolshevik
Revolution was more than an anti work
was a fact of evolution but it is also
true that had the Bolsheviks under Lenin
not decided to oppose Russian
participation or won they would not have
taken out so in a sense although
technically but I I think it's worth
underscoring that for all its you know
whatever we want to say about the
Vietnam War movement and its merits I
think deserves to be seen as one of the
benchmark moments in the opening up in
the democratization
what do you think why did that was that
so
several things first of all by the time
the Vietnam War escalated
there was already a movement
infrastructure there had been years of
the civil rights movement there was a
generation of organizers there were
organizations like SDS which had begun
in 1962 without any particular interest
in Vietnam and in fact without primary
interest in foreign policy I was one of
the people in 1960 four or five trying
to get SDS to pay attention to foreign
policy questions but I was in a minority
in the organization organization had
been formed primarily as a multi-issue
organization to you know to deepen and
enlarge the civil rights movement but it
was an infrastructure there was there
were you know there were communication
it wasn't text message there was US mail
and occasional on business telephone
it matters when there are pre-existing
organs I mean think this is this is a
scratch as an analogy but I think it's I
think historians would agree if if it
were not for the black church there
would not have been supports had we had
a place where people gathered
you had a place where people would talk
to each other about a place where
ministers had a pulpit we didn't we
weren't organized like that and we had
nothing like the presence of it but the
point is basically right we missed them
just come out of the sentiment they
impart and merge from and
or certainly have as their preconditions
that there are networks of communication
trust people who are comfortable with
each other people
for whom the movement is not weird for
whom it's it's becoming second I think
it was in the case of the run-up to the
Iraq war I think it was extremely clear
from the beginning that is from from
from sometime 2002 that the Bush
administration was hell-bent on that one
and it was simply not going to be
dislodged it wasn't just because they
said so Johnson said the same thing
a nick cynicism however I think the
those who opposed the Iraq war
intuited who accurately that Bush mended
and they could into that from having
observed him because that's the con you
know that was the kind of it was
bulldoze and so I think in the apse and
the movements are built on a compound of
sentence I certainly one of them is
angry but also equally certainly another
one is hope I mean it's one thing to go
on you know made huge demonstration
bigger than any single demonstration of
the Vietnam if you think look at it
worldwide definitely but it was a one
day affair and I don't think I mean I
made a way this is retrospective mind
meeting but I think that you know it
sort of felt like a gesture to me like a
gesture of indignation without a whole
lot of a taupe attached to it that there
was actually going to be some momentum
against the world and it's an
interesting thing about public opinion
with respect to the wrong
the publish was actually in many ways a
public even though the initial numbers
of support for Bush once the Lord
started
the numbers were huge but they were
interesting early polls there's a book I
can't remember the name of it now is
published a year to ago by the one of
the former Chiefs of the Gallup poll
the you can ask people a question like
should we go to war before you know
these questions I can't remember the
exact wording should we go to war if we
know there are weapons of mass
destruction we go to work we don't know
should we go to the worthy if the UN is
still inspecting those depending on what
questions you looked at you what you
could you could reasonably see a whole
lot of ambivalence one of the
interesting things that's got pointed
out in writing like the Gallup polls are
get them at the time is when they then
and proceeded to say well if it's living
you know what's your preference so the
majority said go war next question if
your preference is not active how will
you feel about that words to that effect
that is to say how intensely or how
clear are you that your view is the
correct view well then what that
displayed was even more indifference
that is to say yeah people like the idea
of going to war because they believed
Bush and Powell and rest of them on
balance but but not with fervor that is
to say it would not have been bad
politics not to go to war but it was for
the bush people in impossibility so I
think this was somehow pre understood
and that's why these sometimes very
large demonstrations Wow
is one more factor the earliest
anti-iraq ordinance notions in
Washington I'm not sure about here we're
organized by a left-wing sectarian group
they were actually to who
some of them actually white Saddam
Hussein some who sort of we're doing the
equivalent of waving the Vietcong flag
and you know this was a triumph it's a
lot of people know it was because they
were quick they were pretty organized
because those sectarian groups have
continued to exist since sometimes even
before the citizens it so they took the
initiative in organizing one of us but
it did not and it served their
organizational interest but it did not
serve the interests of a significant
number of people I talk to people like
this myself who went down to I would
talk to somebody who heard about one of
these demonstrations in Washington we
say that well I gotta join this went
down to the Washington Monument saw
these signs you know some of them were
you know certainly intensely
anti-american some of them were radical
Palestinian some of them were you know
sweet on Saddam and said the hell with
it I don't want to go near this now had
the American anti-war movement started
out in that it would have had a
self-made hurdle to climb not
as well as successful dances you know
there were booths there with the
communists and whatever and I went wait
a minute I'm not for these people but
but then it became clear to me that they
were just you know using this to further
their own cause button that the bigger
cause was was more people but that I
also some thought that the press partly
covered it all
well that is certainly true not exactly
a Stalin if you've been through the 60s
but still remarkable how downplayed
those early demonstrations
specifically both the New York Times and
The Washington Post by the way one
reason that the demonstration in
February elite was as big as it was was
that enough people had become anti-war
people had become fury ated by the
sectarian groups that they had created a
new coalition trying to leave those
people out of them well they didn't
quite work I mean if you were at that
if you Jumbotrons set up some in the
Trumbo to the foreground of each of the
Jumbotrons there were people wait I
forget what flag they were holding but
they were the people from a group called
answer something or other worth
something racism this is one of those
sectarian groups and they have
positioned themselves even though they
have been cut out of the primary
organizing moment they position
themselves so they were in the floor
group they were like you know smart
political operatives they position
themselves so that theatrically they
look like be working on Isis and that
was the kind of thing that was yeah
they may have been but it wasn't what
they wanted they was no longer they
there were people speaking at that
speaker's platform who they thought were
hopeless wins
you know unsuccessful I mean that the
war became unpopular faster than the
Vietnam War no shame by the way John
Euler demonstrated this published the
book subsequently with the same graph on
Vietnam in Iraq war popularity it's the
same curve I don't think it's true
interested in looking I think I think
they got away with what they wanted and
and what stopped it just as just as with
the Vietnam War in the Korean War that
wouldn't go in any was a lot of America
you know increasing numbers of Americans
were being killed the casualty graph
goes the other way and increasingly
Americans who've been told this was
going to be a cakewalk or something like
that mission accomplished and so on said
on pragmatic growth well the same
a lot of people supported it going in
for the who's Natalie and support early
so the array by the Oh for election I
think polls showed that the majority of
close to majority fought the war but in
Spain but the bush people were
unstoppable
by this point
maybe they got away with it but that a
public-opinion did turn and one factor
you haven't discussed this is economic
reaction and then especially maybe you
know people vote their pocketbooks to
addition to all the damage to American
public image and casualties that you
know the economy was stagnating in both
people vote their pocketbooks but they
don't always know what's in them I don't
think that was a central factor it was
not in a Vietnam case I think later we
come to understand there wasn't until
the war was over that the argument first
began to be made that one of the sources
of the great inflation of the 70s was
the fact that Johnson was drastically
escalated
was understood that it would become
unpopular understood that it would
damage his domestic reform that people
would begin to see a kind of zero-sum
game
figuring that necessary to trend one
behalf of the other and so instead of
raising taxes to pay for the work he
went into debt it's never the way of
disguising the economic consequences
and I really was not they debated issue
and in the big arguments specifically in
the 1968 election or even in the 64
election where Johnson campaign as an
anti on working on the question of the
cost of the war really did not move mark
what Galvin I think the anti-war people
would have said you know even if we're
being paid for this work even if this
war is a profit century the Iraq war is
more complicated partly because it was
so fastly because it was understood that
it was so vastly more expensive
well that was also disguised in some
ways I mean it realized until this year
the bush military budget that was
revealed that was laid out did not
include the cost of American words that
was that was an awful that was a rough
budget item the cost of the Afghanistan
in in rock WA I mean who could make this
up I'm not we have a military budget and
then we have the budget for these two
wars that were running I forget over a
hundred billion dollars I mean I think
Joe Stiglitz over in the economic
support
was one of the first to say this is
gonna be a trillion dollar war he was
just poking that in rock and he was
right but I don't I think that was surf
humming along in the background but I
don't think it by itself was decisive it
certainly you know there certainly was
no me the weight of a way to have
dampened or maybe eliminated the
economic costs of the rock war would
have been to rescind the Bush tax cuts
there was no mass movement to do that in
other ways it would have been a rational
thing if you approve that the Iraq war
to say okay well we've got to have this
war
so let's pay for it you know we raise
taxes in wartime that's what you do
words are expensive employers have
collapsed because they haven't been able
to finance the war there was no not even
not even Liberal Democrats were willing
to do that because it was a loser
Americans didn't wanna raise taxes on
the rich
comment both from your experience but
also in the contemporary on the tension
within anti-war movements or movements
generally between discursiveness and
dogmatism if you pointed to it earlier
when you talked about you know this
group wasn't on message and they weren't
sort of invited into a coalition and
while I understand the need for that and
sort of the political calculus at what
point does a movement become like the
thing that it's moving against in its
attempt to to undo its effort well the
comment on that and Mike from your
experience and also in the contemporary
movements are human contrivance was
nobody in it but human beings for
reasons that are in car built into human
psyches I think having to do with
something trust and so on
and reasons that have to do with social
organization competition political
scientists study this I think there's a
matter where you're talking about it
evangelical churches university
faculties political administrations
there are certain propositions that cut
across lines you can make certain
predictions with you know how how
alliances stabilize and when they don't
stabilize and when people leave and
favorite economist Alfred hurt Albert
Hirschman said then people disagree they
three things they can do they can they
can exit they can voice it was the third
thing next and poise and loyalty they
can stick under what conditions that
people leave when they're angry to what
people what extent did they stay in and
try to change it and so on many
propositions can be trotted out
social scientists
so I don't think there was anything I
don't think there's anything acutely
unusual about this trajectory similar
faction fighting broke out on the right
fact interestingly the the major
right-wing student organization of the
nineties went through a comparable for
the path to stic eventually broke up
around the same time SDS do
interestingly or not because partly over
the war because it was significant
faction there that opposed and partly
over differences which which still are
differences on the right between
libertarians who were for example
against the draft all together and
people all call for sure that status
that people who want the executive have
more power so I don't think there's I
mean yeah it was a very highly charged
atmosphere
that were many political forces at work
and people don't come into social
movement purely become they bring
themselves what they bring in has these
attachments those attachments these dis
attachments so but I think you know so
the the view from the view from some
altitude says this is the story of
social movements
comparison between the media's take
Vietnam shaving and where we're at today
we saw these embedded reporters in Iraq
but the scope of course of their
involvement when they were allowed to
see seemed rather narrow by comparison
with those who reported Vietnam Lois
group common today when one thinks about
what's going on with newspapers it's
even more frightening about what we know
and don't know about what well yeah
that's very important you know a heart
and hard as it may be to believe from
today's vantage a lot of them really
excellent I mean I'd say the great bulk
of the coverage of the Vietnam War
was made possible by the US military I
mean reporters were ferried around the
country on
when all if none of them was shot in the
back and you know and they were treated
respectfully it was not yet a piece of
the military's conventional wisdom that
the press is stabbing us in the back so
the dynamic it wasn't that most
reporters who covered the war were
against the war I mean David Halberstam
probably the most revered and famous in
any influential of these reporters would
actually publicly spoke in behalf of the
war up through a believer in 1966 he
finally decided it was a quagmire but
that didn't mean he thought it would
have been a bad idea I thought man it
was we're stuck but he actually did
think it was a noble effort for some
time
here's what the press this is what drove
the press crazy they would go out they'd
see things happen and see Americans
clearing or Americans and personally saw
that the Saigon Army wouldn't play
secondly they saw Americans clearing a
turret and clearing a village and so on
and then at night no you can't go there
why because it's controlled by the
Vietcong goes on so they go to the
military command which every day holds a
briefing which was known as the five
o'clock follies and they'd say well what
about this and the military spokesman
say that didn't happen what are you
gonna believe me or not I mean quite
seriously what what the major force in
driving the Vietnam reporters away from
the war was the discrepancy between what
they observed and what the military was
telling them the story they would laugh
and
and by the way it's there was no
censorship and there was no minor system
interestingly I don't know whether how
well this is established and I don't I
once was giving a talk in Washington
about the entity it was a guy in the
audience who worked at the Pentagon in
the PR office and he said that the NBC
News had come at some point through the
Vietnam War I actually come to the
Pentagon and asked them to impose
censorship because they were kind of
queasy about what they were showing I
don't really didn't want to do it I mean
that's a different world I got a I can't
confirm it but I thought it was kind of
a startling but somebody would even you
know this was a career Pentagon
bureaucrat
I think that the military change in its
relation to the pressing part because of
what felt to them like the catastrophe
of Vietnam is referring important you
know the military collapsed I mean that
the main thing you care about it I mean
yes of course you're a patriot if you
were in the military but you also care
about you guys and you know your thing
fell apart so they went to work to make
sure that would never happen again many
interesting things Oliver from that one
thing that follows from that was we
don't do a long Wars a good weekend
for years we did only weekend you know
Ronald Reagan sent I forget how many
thousands of troops to a route and they
were on duty there and then I forget
which Islamist faction grew up from
Arabs who killed 241 American marines
and Ronald Reagan the most belligerent
talking American president in decades
what are you doing we drew the troops
jimena Johnson say we're not going to
tuck tail and run he tucked tail and ran
and then turn around and invaded the
island of Grenada which is about the
size of Berkeley California so we could
claim a victory he really thought it
wasn't until the Gulf War the first of
all that were that the military was
actually interested in Wars and we we
know we knew that and we know now that
the military Powell in particular were
actually fairly skeptical about the
first offer and
first Caspar Weinberger who was
Secretary of Defense on Reagan and then
al enunciated doctors you know
conditions under which we should go into
word and that's when we started hearing
about exit strategies and popular
support so don't start these wrong wars
that are unsustainable and that are bad
for the country George Bush Senior was
very shrewd in the way he approached the
first Gulf War but we're getting in
organizing it as an international
expedition with UN sanction getting it
paid for by the Japanese and the Saudis
I mean that was rather brilliantly
pursued operation just as as a way of
leaping over the early that had been
placed by the military as they didn't
want to do Vietnam again
it left a very bad taste and this will
also led to the system of controlling
precedent so in in the first Gulf War it
was it was the mine it was they set up
groups of reporters whom they tumbled
around you couldn't just hitch a ride in
the helicopter I'm not saying that would
work tit job but it was also among other
things made it a lot easier to control
important and then of course yet even
more so in the case
that's I think I drifted away from the
question looking forward with so few oh
right you know this is this is really
terrible a few months ago I don't know
if you were there gentlemen one of our
PhD students brought to speak to our
program a friend of hers who had been
for five years the Chicago Tribune
correspondent in South Asia so really
that's a lot to cover by India Pakistan
Afghanistan she was in and she
talk to us about Afghanistan why was she
here in New York well because after five
years on the strong a lot of in covering
Afghanistan the Chicago Tribune which
was about to declare bankruptcy had told
her to come home and other work in Metro
Europe and she quit
it's we hadn't got down to zero we still
have one serious newspaper I'll tell you
another story I had an old friend from
college who became a Washington Post
foreign he took but most of the
experience people here to the buyout
because they're down more the more
experience that he's also all of the
read more expensive people were bored
out so so he said he'd gone over there
for meeting recently and there used to
be in Washington Post newsroom big globe
that with pinpoint sort of flags or
something
you know here's where we have our
bureaus now even in the good old days
the washington post one of our major
newspapers not that widely dispersed I
actually had a good friend who was for a
couple of years the Washington Post
South America bureau chief she was based
in Buenos Aires with a with an assistant
and her job was South America but okay
but they they had some it had been a you
know a pin on Poydras its own
well they've taken the globe away it's
no longer in the room and my friend said
you know obviously it's an embarrassment
because anybody has been around with
recognize how the error is the Boston
Globe has closed all its Farm Bureau's
that the Baltimore Sun closed for the
Chicago Tribune I think is in the
process but none of the networks I mean
this has really been an old story
everybody has one of the best reporters
of the Vietnam War still in touch with
that at CBS and ABC it covered a lot of
other words but for many years even in
the 70s he was based in London and he
was being parachuted in you know
everywhere including the Middle East
there was no bureau he covered the Iran
Revolution there was no you see them to
have anybody in chilla
and you know he's wonderful reporter but
he's not a Farsi speaker I mean he'd be
the first to say this is crazy so it's
more than me going in that direction
anyway now of course it's precipitously
you know I mean I look you know I look
at the New York Times better how many of
you read read the new entrances you were
more than my students
you know it's still kind of a great deal
for two bucks
you can get out of it but you know it's
not getting any cheaper it's not the
dead tree version of it is not
circulating Finster I mean to me it's
kind of miraculous that that it's still
as good as it is that one one thing he
would have seen if he read it dead tree
or like zoom online is a picture of a of
the tribes news reported quite unusual
and the reason there's a picture of the
time loop through someone inside pages
that will reporter named David Rohde
just came back to New York and was being
greeted by
publisher and his understand why is this
a big deal because David wrote want to
quote surprise in the years ago recovery
Pakistan was kidnapped by Taliban
November and only last week or two weeks
ago escaped after being imprisoned for
something like seven seventeen
so he was being greeted people like
David wrote David wrote is 41 years old
he's obviously
you know people like David Rohde have to
want to do this sort of thing he was
actually working on a book so it read
the Taliban and had agreed to go meet
some meaning go to meet some Taliban
honcho and kidnapped in the course of
that if we're going to learn about what
is going on in places like Afghanistan
they need to be people like David
Rolland who do you know go out there and
sometimes our foolhardy but mostly non
there are eyes and ears I say places
like Afghanistan me well we're ready
virtually aborted Somalia but I don't
know that there are any Somali is a very
dangerous places if he's one of these
failed States no state they Islamist
factions kind of sort of people who it's
speculated at least decoys partly
because of the drone attacks in
Afghanistan Pakistan a lot of the
al-qaeda people
to the corner of Africa we should have
more reporting of what's going on so to
me it's kind of wonderful that there are
still people who want to come to
journalism school would be journalism
application went up 40% most but I think
it's kind of inspiring because they all
I think anybody who's coming to the
journalism school discipline and they
are coming understands that they're not
going to have the kind of career that
David Rohde thought rode started at the
Christian Science Monitor than the times
higher you know he can probably spend
the rest of his career at the time
that's you know two or three jobs was
the old sort of mainline
journalism career if you a good foreign
correspondent you know you got to do it
for many years we have a man on the
faculty at Howard French represent at
the times Haiti in various places in
Africa most recently in China people
like him who could do 20 30 years of
your time those jobs are going to be
scarce or against you so people now
people who care about Journal is
especially foreign journalism in the
process of working on some sort of
improvisational life where you do a lot
of freelancing go from one thing to
another don't expect to lessen its I
don't think journalism is gonna go away
but I think it's obviously a huge
disconnection between the world of
journalism and they know when you talk
about journalism and according to John
Mueller so did the needle move at all
with the live massacre and Abu Ghraib
I think if you take two
okay good question in the case of the
v/line massacre if memory serves the
massacre took place in the fall of 68
but was not actually made public until
69 I believe that's there was certainly
a gap I'm not sure of significant number
of months and then you know what most
people the way most people learn about
the Milan massacre was these astounding
color photos that appeared had been
taken by a I believe a soldier they
ended up in Life magazine which was then
a mass key it's like the television by
that time the war was already full of
popularity was we're ready down in this
territory we're ready
so yeah I'm sure if you looked at the
detailed public opinion figures I'm sure
the war by various measures would be
you know got a bump down in popular
early it certainly is true I have seen
the figures for Abu Ghraib but I can't
remember them at the moment but I'm sure
that it's a mistake to draw these as
certainly bumpy with respect to Iraq and
Abu Ghraib is a real benchmark those
photos first appeared in the spring of
o4 shortly thereafter I think it
probably did bump support for the war on
what exhibit whatever exactly it meant
at that point don't go the war is a
clear position get out is not quite such
a clue
I'm sure that it kicked the numbers
support for the moreover for the
satisfied man but at a time when
according to some polls but most
Americans had already turned against the
war they were still not willing to vote
for John Kerry the number had gone at
something that below 50% but no buts
were over for about six months after the
photos so yeah these things matter but
they're not by themselves decisive
- the American physicians at the war
because I don't know it seems like after
9/11 there was a need for our America to
strengthen the international community
and maybe in aggressive Vietnam there
wasn't that same meet because
look that's certainly true that's that's
important
although and you know the the
precipitating incident supported as most
Americans knew that led to this big
escalation in 1965 was an attack in
February of that year on American
barracks I think was a mortar attack and
it's a certain number of American troops
who killed
and so supporters we outside Washington
knew you know the big escalation sending
greensly
Martin of North Vietnam was a response
but in fact that response had been
prepared for months
in fact george bundy who was one of the
major decision makers in the escalation
war made it made it became a notorious
remark what this event in february 65
was barracks at a place called pleiku
and he said you know it is it publicly
but it came it's now accepted that he
did say to somebody play coos are white
streetcars they come along and every so
often so this was just a convenience now
September 11th was not a convenience
September 11th is not like this report
it's you know was unique and so
obviously the state of a mirror of the
American mind was far more
open predisposed to accepting a certain
story about the rock that connected it
to September 11th and which use that
Detroit Lee and even then it's
interesting how much skepticism there
was in the run-up to the war
so I would say that this impulse not to
go to war there's still the Vietnam War
still worship it's it's harder to get
Americans to war citizen even given the
recent incident I mentioned that Reagan
was you know Rico NATO was a weekend war
Bush had a weekend where Panama and went
and snatched general Noriega that the
best they could be Reagan also
increasingly what Americans with
American governments try to do was to
pay proxies to go to war for us we had a
series of those we you know we funded
the Contras in Nicaragua we funded the
death squads in El Salvador we funded
the Mujahideen in Afghanistan against
the Soviets that was a way of having in
Warwick not having Americans die and
that still I think Americans preference
although obviously September 11 did
change one
sending 21 thousand more troops to
Afghanistan for example didn't seem to
be confident in a year but I think there
was a sea change
the default position instead of being
goggle warm when you know the world with
some alacrity became that's not
and it did take this immense you know
catastrophic event to put Americans at
least for a while
into different statement
we're african-americans they were very
connected and I also was wondering if
it's true that many yeah that's that's
part of what happened the persecuted the
time sequence is interesting the I think
I think it's fair to say that that the
perception of most civil rights
organizers minor most but certainly
significant numbers is by 1964 five is
that the civil rights movement has as
given what it's set out to do is
basically one or it's in the you know
it's in the process of winning the Civil
Rights Act 1964 the Voting Rights Act
1965 segregation is on its last legs and
then and if so civil rights again it's
predictable from way movements work that
you get then clashes here some people
want to radicalize black power comes
from that
but and and and what went along with
that in part was the purging of at least
in the more radical organization in a
particular purging of white organizers
quite a number of them actually did go
into the end and and if you again if you
looked at the organization like SDS
which had a lot of its impetus from
being the kind of support arm of the
civil rights starting from the citizens
in 1960
if you should looking for a way to enter
history
especially if your wife
yeah the civil rights movement has less
place for you and obviously the anti-war
movement has some kind of commanding
presence people who haven't been very
interested suddenly extremely
other leaders in SDS who've been very
skeptical about the anti-war coming up
to me
exuberant because he thought this was
sort of a diversion he didn't
making an obviously this party
organization
frivolous
is what we really should be doing
organizing it for
so yeah infrastructure individuals
specifically White's the clergy also
who've been deeply involved in the civil
rights
and then people that sort of burned out
I mean one of the speakers at that first
big national demonstration that SDS were
there was Bob Moses who had been one of
the key leaders of snake they stood and
then more than anyone else responsible
for the Great Mississippi project I had
so much to do
me you know basically burned out my
experience was actually on his way
becoming a next act he was one of the
speakers at
the freedom singers were sort of the
official troubadour group of the civil
rights movement they sang at that well
so there were these converging there's a
pretty small world than we intended to
know each other there's a lot of back
and forth in the the draft resistance
movement
was heavily organised by veterans of the
Civil Rights Borrowed
strategy and I cannot Rafi
other veterans of the Civil Rights woman
became early organizers of like what I
guess you could call the scoop that is
to say the Free Speech Movement in
Berkeley related sort of articulating
the idea that the university should be
placed for political community that
works against Authority pretty speech
which was the one that kicked off that
cycle in the fall of six before you
noted it's all happening around the same
time those people some of them have been
organizing in Mississippi in the civil
rights movement this summer and after
the Free Speech Movement they then many
of them became early leaders especially
at Berkeley of the anti-war movement so
there was this sort of moving picket of
-